Speaker 1: We're going to look at how a conspiracy
theory gets oxygen and grows and grows. And it can
very, very quickly become so big that even
finding out it's not true won't debunk it
for the people perpetuating it. Wait, what am I.
What am I talking about? I'm going to show you I'm
going to show you the genesis of a conspiracy,
some might say, the fringes of a conspiracy,
for lack of a better term. We're going to look at
an interview on the Joe Rogan podcast with a guy.
Who is he? He goes by the name Joe Tap
Jesus. I guess his name is Brian Sharp,
but he goes by Joe Tap Jesus himself, a
spreader of conspiracy theories of all kinds.
Joe Tap Jesus has previously said that
the Atlantic slave trade was a myth,
that the vast majority of African-Americans
are the original Native Americans and many
other conspiracy theories. Okay. Joe Tap,
Jesus appears on the Joe Rogan program,
and Joe Rogan brings up that the widely debunked
claim that Australia was going to pass a law
to ban anybody from growing their own food. You
know how I grow my radishes and my cooks and my
zouks in the backyard, all of that stuff. The the
claim from Rogan is in Australia that would be
against the law. Now it's not true. We're going
to look at the clip and I want you to really
look at first how long they spend talking about
how terrible it is that Australia is doing this
until they get the idea to look for an article.
They can't find any articles. And then Rogan goes,
Oh man, it might not be a real story, but then ho
tep Jesus says, even if it's fake, the fact that
you thought it is probably a warning that they're
going to do it at some point. And this is the
epitome of not finding evidence fuels us believing
it's probably true because maybe the evidence is
being hidden that this is a genius and genius in
a terrible way. Clinic on Conspiratorial Thinking.
And they spent a bunch of this episode slamming
so-called fake news, and then they fell for it
and they perpetuated it. Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: You know, I want to find out what
this is, but I read something briefly
and I didn't get into the article,
but they were saying that they were trying to
pass a bill that would outlaw you growing your own
food in Australia. Oh, my God. Oh, my God. Did
you read that? No, it was a part of Australia.
I think it was New South Wales. Okay. Someone's
trying to pass a law that won't allow you to grow
your own food. And they were saying, well,
you've got to grow your own. Hold on. What
I thought those things were was from your food.
Speaker 1: So now Rogan is ridiculing the things
that the people saying growing your own food
is bad supposedly said, but the whole story is
fake. Now they're ridiculing imaginary people.
Speaker 2: And in fact, the population kill
all people and have that pull that. I want
to know what what their justification was,
but I'm pretty sure it had to do with
like agricultural contamination or,
you know, I mean, you could justify it if
you're a real piece of shit. You could say,
well, you know, most pandemics
have come from agriculture,
animal agriculture. We can have unchecked pig
ownership. That's not fair. We can. You've
grown vegetables. What have your vegetables
ever got? In a moment. Disease creeps, man.
It's okay, GREAVES. They. They got a good grip on
people during the pandemic. They locked everybody
down, not showing them, you know what? We're going
to stop this one if we're all in there on food,
because that's how you smoke out an anti-vaxxer.
Speaker 1: And look at now. Now the story is
fake and it's now being built up into this is
part of the control. You tell people you go
crazy in Australia with COVID, you tell
people they can't go to the grocery store
and they can't grow their own food in order
to force anti-vaxxers to go and get themselves
vaccinated because otherwise they'll starve.
It's a three layer conspiracy theory now,
all based on nothing, and now is when it starts
to turn and they go, Maybe we should find
some evidence that this actually is happening.
Speaker 2: May make you can't even go there, go
to the grocery store anymore and you
can't grow your food. No dependent.
Take that chocolate chip. You find
anything you are now dependent upon
passes, Bill. And I know what to look for.
I'm just said it's not. Nothing's coming up.
The closest thing I could find was something
like this. I know that's not new food now.
It's not. It's not in New Zealand, it's in it's in
Australia. I know but this is close to New Zealand
is like right around the corner could.
Speaker 1: Have right there's
doesn't matter that Rogan's talking about
Australia. If they find it in New Zealand
it's close enough but it's not there either.
Speaker 2: It's got to be a real thing. It
seems too good to not be. It's obviously it's
an outlaw growing food in Australia and nothing,
not a single thing comes up. Oh. Hold on.
Except for that. Which was a false thing.
Growing your own food. They want. They want us
completely dependent.
Speaker 1:
So what's happened now? He's unfazed by the fact
that there's no evidence of this story. He's like
this. This is part of them wanting us dependent.
Speaker 2: Yeah. I can't find it either. Dammit.
Better not be fake. It might be fake,
but even if it's fake, right? Like,
the fake is usually the warning.
Even if it's fake, the fake
is usually the warning.
Speaker 1: That's like the that's the
epitome of these people. If they had
found an article saying this was happening
in Australia, the article would be the proof.
They didn't find the article, so it was a fake
story. Now that's the proof. It's probably coming
because the fake stories usually come before
it becomes a real story. It's the warning.
This is unbelievable. And almost 3 minutes, half
of which is just building on. They don't want to
let you grow their own food. Well, that's not
true. The reason they don't want to do it is
to smoke out anti-vaxxers, to force them to go and
get vaccinated by making them unable to grow their
own food and not letting them go to grocery stores
unless they're back. So that's layer number two.
Layer number three. This is part of the
general. They want to control you and
they want you to be dependent. It turns out
it's not real. Oh, well, it doesn't matter.
It's probably the fact that you thought it
was is a sign that at some point it will be.
And one of the most brilliant things is as
Rogan starts to realize, it's fake, the guest
doesn't care. And hosts have Jesus is like filling
the dead air by saying they want us dependent.
They want to control us. He's not even reacting
to the fact that there's no story. He just keeps
going, filling the dead air. And it hits all the
points of conspiratorial thinking, including that
the absence of evidence. Rogan thought it. They
find no evidence. That's part of the conspiracy.
That's probably a sign that it's coming. It is
text book clinic on this stuff. And by the way,
they almost seem disappointed that it's not true.
It would be terrible if you weren't allowed to
grow your own food. They should be overjoyed.
Oh, my God. What great news. You can grow your
own food in Australia. You can do it. They're not
overjoyed. They're almost, like, bummed out that
the story's not real. Unbelievable stuff. Scary.
And probably a bunch of people still came away
from that, believing that it's true that Australia
won't let you grow your own food. Scary stuff.